this video is sponsored by delete me get
your personal information removed from
online search results and data Brokers
using the link in the description also
if you enjoy this video or pursuit of
Wonder content in general I think you'll
also really enjoy my books the links for
them are in the description as well
this was Cam and his girlfriend Maria's
third time moving to a different city in
the last four years
this time they were moving to a lively
neighborhood called Montrose in Houston
Texas this was also the fourth time
camera changed jobs in the prior five
years or so he had worked in marketing
for an electronics company than Sales
Management for a software company than
operations management for a
Manufacturing Company he had found some
traditional success but repeatedly he
seemed to find himself in the same spot
just unsatisfied enough with his job his
trajectory his life to want something
else time and time again he felt like he
wasn't doing anything impressive or
important enough he longed for
significance status wealth purpose
[Music]
Maria worked remotely as a costume
designer for a major video game
publisher so she had the flexibility to
move basically anywhere in the country
she enjoyed her job and planned on
staying but like cam she also sought
excitement and newness and a greater
sense of something else that they could
never quite pin down but felt was
missing and so she was on board for
another move
after a couple months of looking and
applying for better higher paying jobs
in bigger cities cam received a job
offer for a business development manager
position for a subsea and Space
Engineering and technology company in
Houston without any hesitation he took
it and he and Maria plan their move
now several weeks later they were
settling into their new condo and
Montrose unpacking and organizing their
stuff they brought everything with them
the second Monday after moving in was
Camp's first day he drove into the
industrial park where the business was
located walked into the large building
and started Anew again
after work cam returned home spent some
time finishing unpacking then relaxing
eating and sleeping
this mostly repeated for the rest of the
week
on that Friday Cam and Maria went out to
eat at a new restaurant close to them
called marmo after taking a sip of her
drink Maria looked over at Cam and asked
so what's the conclusion how the first
week go
good
Cam said just good no no like it's been
good fairly typical so far mostly just
getting me up to speed on stuff being
introduced to people and the culture and
goals and all that I've mostly been
doing market research reading reports
and lots of emails it's different but
familiar if that makes sense I'm excited
though should be a really great jumping
off point for something even better in
the future that's awesome babe Maria
said yeah cam responded
the rest of the weekend and subsequent
week rotated right by similar to the
last on the following Saturday while
cleaning up the kitchen Maria blurted
out to cam oh my God it's endless what
the dust I Feel Like We just cleaned
this place and it's already filthy again
where does all the dust even come from I
know seriously cam responded it's an
eternal fight against dirt and dust and
dirt and dust always win she said with a
somewhat humorous tone yeah I guess we
must be Dusty Camp said in a similar
tone
hey we should go for a walk around the
neighborhood a little bit Maria said
changing the subject yeah I'm down when
do you want to go how about in like 15
minutes sure yeah sounds good I just
need to get changed Camp said the two
finish what they were doing left their
apartment and began their walk around
the neighborhood
after around 15 minutes they passed by a
house with an older man in the front
yard he looked like he was perhaps in
his 50s or 60s he was digging what
appeared to be a large hole
all in a day's work the man suddenly
said gesturing his head toward Cam and
Maria Cam and Maria waved as they
laughed with a sort of tight-lip smile
and downward head nod
some nice people around here huh Cam
said to Maria and a bit of a humorous
but sincere tone as they continued past
the house yeah love that Maria responded
the two walked for another 15 minutes or
so and then returned home
throughout the rest of the week Cam and
Maria began going on walks more
regularly they walked all sorts of
directions and routes exploring
different pockets of the neighborhood
and the city more broadly
walking became one of the most enjoyable
parts of their day there was no real
goal besides enjoying themselves and no
real destination besides back where they
started a walking habit began to set in
amidst their newly forming routine work
eat walk clean TV sleep repeat a local
activity and a few drinks in a meal at a
new restaurant sprinkled in here and
there simultaneously the gears of Cam's
new job were also beginning to turn the
newness became normalness
cam liked the job but he had soon found
himself feeling mostly the same as he
had at his previous jobs
a quiet familiar fear that this new job
wouldn't amount to anything that would
profoundly satisfy that feeling of
something missing that pit began to
enter into the back of his mind
on the following Saturday Cam and Maria
walked the same relative route that they
had the previous Saturday around 15
minutes in they approached the same
house where the older man had been out
front digging to their surprise he was
still out front digging it appeared to
be the same hole in the same spot
when the man noticed them he looked up
all in a day's work
Cam and Maria waved while laughing out
of their nose with a tight-lip smile but
this time their laugh was a bit hesitant
and Confused
hasn't made much progress huh cam
quietly said to Maria as they kept
walking yeah I know weird it almost
looks like he's less far along Maria
said he must have just not gotten a good
angle cam replied hmm Maria responded
the two continued walking past the
subsequent houses
what do you think he's taking cam asked
who knows maybe he's looking for
something
after around another 20 minutes or so
the two finished their walk and returned
home
four days later on Wednesday at around 7
30 PM camo Maria went for a walk the sun
had set and the streets were illuminated
only by the glow of buildings driveway
lights and street lights after around 25
minutes someone under his breath cam
suddenly said what the hell he
discreetly pointed slightly to the side
and in front of where they were walking
there was the same older man standing
out front of the same house digging the
same hole in the same spot it's like the
same size am I tripping cam continued no
it definitely looks the same Maria said
with a subtle laugh the man looked up
all in a day's work he said gesturing
his head toward them Cam and Maria
didn't laugh still digging Cam said with
a half smile and playful but almost
concerned tone Oh yeah just getting
started the man responded completely
thrown off cam responded what what are
you digging making a koi pond for my son
he turned his head and pointed toward
the house behind him Cam and Maria
followed his gaze toward the house
all the windows were covered by Shades
leaning up against the house Kim noticed
another shovel the blade was covered in
dirt
as they were inspecting the house
someone inside pulled one of the window
shades back a younger man's face
appeared in the small space between the
window frame and the shade the man
looked out at them holding still for a
moment like he was making sure
everything was okay
he was hard to see backlit and shadowed
by the interior of the home
then the shade closed both Cam and Maria
redirected their attention back toward
the old man who had now resumed digging
in synchronization they both realized
what they were observing the muscles on
both their faces began to slightly droop
that's awesome Camp said his voice
containing a forced kind of enthusiasm
koi fish a symbol of courage and
perseverance right he continued I don't
know the man said I just like him fair
enough Maria added with a laugh well
have a good one cam concluded yup you
too
Cam and Maria continued walking they
were silent for a moment Maria's eyes
were wide like she was forcing them open
she turned around and looked behind her
ensuring they were far enough away
oh my God she said that's so sad that
literally makes me wanna
life is so shitty dude I know Cam said
his voice shaking a bit we don't know
exactly what's going on though come on
cam he probably has dementia or
something every day he's just digging
that same hole to Nowhere for nothing oh
my God her eyes began to water could be
like a head injury or brain damage or
tumor or something cam added okay so
either way everything we know everything
we think and believe everything we are
it's all just limited to the clump of
paste inside her head destined to
shrivel up we're just memories and
memories are just brain tissue oh my God
I'm done
there was a brief silence
so what do you think his son or whoever
is like refilling the hole every night
yeah I guess must be Mario responded
Jesus digging a hole every day just for
it to be filled up as soon as you finish
and then starting again every morning
never achieving what you're after your
effort's never really amounting to
anything God
cam looked around them then he looked
down at his feet moving left right left
right left right
[Music]
the two quickly finished their walk not
feeling much like continuing or doing
anything else
a few days later on Sunday Maria was
catching up on some work at the
apartment cam spent most of the
afternoon cleaning organizing watching
some TV and walking around the
neighborhood by himself at some point
out of morbid curiosity he walked by the
man's house
there he was digging same spot same hole
the man looked up noticing cam who had
unintentionally stopped and was now
staring at him all in a day's work the
man said as he nodded yeah Cam said all
in a day's work
cam continued standing there for a
moment it must have been long because
the man looked up again
beautiful day isn't it the man said
looking up at the sky just gorgeous
he seemed completely sincere then he
continued digging cam forced a smile and
nodded yes yeah it is he said mostly to
himself
then he continued walking
later that night while eating dinner
with Maria Cam said
maybe that guy the guy who digs in front
of his house
maybe he's happy as much as anyone can
be at least Maria swallowed her food and
looked over at cam maybe she said not so
sure about it I want to imagine he's
happy at least Camp said what could his
imagining it's what's real that matters
right
yeah I guess you're right he seemed
happy to me today though when I walked
by
oh yeah well that's a nice thought maybe
he is maybe because he believes there's
hope that eventually he'll finish
digging and the koi pond will be
complete
I wonder if somehow he could know that
it wasn't could he ever be happy then
can't pause for a moment
Maybe
one can accept that truth and maybe
accepting that truth in a way conquers
it it's not like he's doing anything
different either way whether it ends up
being finished or not in his head today
he's just digging maybe it's all just in
our heads
what do you mean Maria interrupted
maybe even if one knows that by
Nightfall their task their project their
life will surmount to hopeless and
futile efforts endless digging they can
still look around and see that it's a
beautiful day they can still be with
people they love they can still be
present in what they're doing
they can still try
maybe one simply must try to be happy
hmm Maria said I like that she took
another bite of her food
the next day on Monday cam intently
kissed Maria goodbye in the morning and
left for work on his drive he observed
all the houses and businesses the
different architectural Styles the cars
and people the patterns the colors the
sensations he played one of his new
favorite songs
he rolled the window down and felt the
air and sun on his skin
then
he laughed
[Music]
this video was sponsored by delete me as
someone who covets their privacy it can
be incredibly frustrating and difficult
dealing with maintaining it online
especially as someone who's online in so
many ways personal information is so
strangely vulnerable on the internet
without your consent it can be actively
collected by companies known as data
Brokers and then sold to third parties
their product is your personal
information having things out there like
your home address contact information
and financial records is not only
disconcerting but it can lead to real
things like fraud harassment and scams
you can remove all this information but
it's incredibly time consuming confusing
and is like playing an endless game of
whack-a-mole delete me however solves
this problem and essentially just
unplugs the game for you delete me as a
subscription service that removes your
personal information from hundreds of
data broker websites for you it's super
easy to use and makes the process simple
all you have to do is submit what
personal information you want removed
and in seven days you'll get a privacy
report from delete me showing what was
found where and where it was removed
then every three months you'll continue
to receive reports with Updates this is
perhaps one of the best parts of delete
me service their software and team of
experts automatically continue to
monitor sites and repeat removals for
you and you can submit custom removal
requests at any time on average delete
me finds and removes over 2 000 pieces
of data for a single person in their
first two years so if you want
potentially two thousand pieces of your
personal private information to remain
personal and private sign up to delete
me using the link in the description and
use code Wonder 20 at checkout to
receive twenty percent off
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]